I have to play this for you
unfortunately uh the view invited saying
I don't have to play it but I'm going to
uh the view invited singers Natasha
Bedingfield and
milck is it milk
pronounce milk anyway so there's two
women to come perform an anti-gun song
called your child my child
and uh I know you're thinking
musical performance at the view it must
already already be terrible uh it's an
anti-gun song it must be even worse
and I'm here to tell you that it's
a lot worse than you even expect let's
listen to some of this
[Music]
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
enough
um they have a point enough that's a
that's that's enough of that uh so so
that that's but that is their point uh I
don't know if you picked up one but
enough
they're saying enough enough just enough
all right
the only thing we're missing from that
song is more dramatic hand waving and
head bobbing I think that's that there
wasn't there was not enough of that we
needed we needed more of that a little
bit more
um but what I love about this is that
first of all it's yet more evidence that
the left doesn't know how to get their
point across through ART anymore
and this is actually a great development
for the culture uh if not for our
eardrums
because because everything now it's
great development because because you
know it's it's
the more effective they are getting
their ideas across the worse it is
um so the trade-off is that we have a
lot of really bad terrible art but the
but the the only plus side is that is
they're not nearly as effective
that's uh conveying their ideas and
getting people to accept them because
everything now is two on the nose too
melodramatic too overly political
overtly political I should say
um and they used to be much more subtle
you know they used to embed their
messaging into art that on the surface
seem to have nothing to do with politics
and that was always the most effective
approach but they don't do that anymore
and I think there are a lot of reasons
for that they're just just they're far
too ideological at this point
uh there's a there's a real skill
problem as well they don't this the the
they don't have the same level of talent
anymore thanks to rough greens my dog
has Boundless Energy and infectious
happiness that continues to brighten the
lives of everyone who meets them
especially me our pup stays are filled
with laughter exercise and endless fun
which is so important to me
that the dog has fun so excited about it
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough grains is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
little did I know before I got rough
greens that dog food is dead food
everybody knows nutrition isn't Brown
it's green let rough greens boost your
dog's food back to life rough grains is
a supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough grains on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough grains
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are we eat and that goes for
dogs too naturopathic under dance black
is so confident rough grains will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jumpstart trial bag
so your dog can try it a free jumpstart
trial bag can be at your door and just a
few business days go to roughgreens.com
mat or call 844 rough 700 that's Ruff
greens.com or call 844 rough 700 today
and the second thing I like about this
this is a really great summation it's a
great representation of the gun control
movement
because this is actually all they have
to say
enough enough someone do something
and uh they say that you know in the
song they say that when enough of us cry
out then the gun violence will stop and
I know you might think it was just a
song they don't mean that literally but
but that is literally the anti-gun point
of view they think that if we that we
can reach a point
where people get sick of gun violence
and we pass some kind of magical law and
it stops
but that of course is not the case gun
violence committed by bad violent people
with ill intent
will always be a problem you can't make
it go away
you can't make it disappear
especially not with laws
and the reason we know that is because
the world has has always been a very
violent place and it was a very violent
place
probably in many ways more violent
before guns even existed
so this is human nature unfortunately
uh it's the way of the world
now does that mean that we can't do
anything about it doesn't mean we should
accept it and surrender ourselves to it
absolutely not
what it means is that we must emphasize
two things in society and one is justice
punishing the bad guys punishing harshly
and swiftly and two is self-defense
which requires guns whether you like it
or not if you'd like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt Walsh Show Twitter page hope to
see you there Godspeed